[Music]
students who's who joins this program
has an opportunity to get a taste for
all the different possibilities of what
it means to be an architect and what
kind of mental faculties that is
required by the profession that could
potentially lead to other types of jobs
and careers I think it's so easy for
students to come into a program like
this assuming what architecture is just
because they've not been exposed to
architecture it's not simply Pazhani
it's more about a language between the
space and people walking through the
space I started doing things differently
and I think it's always very enriching
to be able to see the different
perspectives you're learning so much
that you wouldn't learn anywhere else
and there are so many resources here
like the deep dive lab and the
professors themselves and spike-like
everyone is just they're so helpful they
really care about your work and they
want you to care about your work too the
TAS really were there for us and like
helping build so many help sessions and
like went through all of it with us and
I've learned so much from that so much
more than I would from ever just say to
the class I learned how to use Photoshop
and Rhino to build models for the Rhino
part I struggled a lot at first because
it was a totally new program to us they
did a really great job kind of teaching
us how to do it and like starting off
the basic exercises so now I feel like
I'm comfortable enough to build models
on my own the satisfaction of finally
getting it was I think we're all
multiple multiple tribes of trying to do
it and it's really cool just to see like
the actual process that real architects
take and not just your teachers and do
this do that they give us all the
resources but it's up to us to figure it
out and it's so universal you can do
anything with it you're learning any
design skill that applies to everything
and I'll have to just go on this
straight path the architecture it's like
architecture and theater architecture
and music there's so much you can do
and gives students an opportunity to
really kind of find something that
they're interested in that relates back
to architecture I think that's what we
really want to have happen here not only
did this help me like decide whether or
not I want to do architecture a lot of
my friends you know they're having
trouble decide like what kind of college
don't want like city life large campus
small campus like population size and I
think just you don't want to come here
in Pittsburgh and you know study
something I find super interesting it
was just a great opportunity and it's
definitely gonna be a whole lot of
helpful in the future
[Music]